I am Nicholas be with reason TV and we
are in Las Vegas at Freedom Fest and
we're talking to Donald Smith a reason
contributor but also a investor
extraordinaire done thanks for talking
to us my pleasure done all we hear about
now our apocalyptic scenarios you know
and that's coming from the Treasury
secretary saying if we don't raise the
debt limit by August second we're toast
he's assigning a lot like the previous
Treasury secretary said who didn't pass
tarp over a long weekend we were toast
how bad is the current economic
situation when we have a government that
is massively in debt where we have
markets that are tumbling are things as
bad as a we seem to keep hearing on the
news I don't think so at least not in
the United States you know a lot of this
is actually healthy for first time we're
talking about debt and we're talking
about doing something so a lot of the
stuff the fact that we're just talking
about the problem and maybe we're going
to kick the can down the road a little
ways but you know grease suit was a
wake-up called all of us and I think
politicians know it and so hopefully
something will be done but even if it's
not done near-term you know I'm pretty
constructive on some cheap value stocks
because where else are people going to
put their money it's really the it's the
best of a lot of part alternatives which
I consider you know commodities look
like they're in a topping action bonds
government bonds or looks like they've
been in a in a boom and could be topping
out so there's a lot of money out there
and it's you know money market funds are
yielding nothing there's an over 1.5
trillion dollars in money market funds
if anything you might even worry about
money market funds if Europe goes down
that you know some of the money markets
might break the buck again and you got
the lot of money in municipal and that's
a concern so it seems like stocks are
the place to be and you're kind of
bullish about the future though do you
think it's likely that the government
you know the US federal government is
we're going to take it take its size and
scope down to you know to a point where
in the near future it's actually only
spending what it brings in that a
tackles deficit that things like that or
is it just something that we will try
and build some kind of work around on I
think it's just we're trying to figure
out ways to kick the can down the road
and then some countries can't do it any
longer like Greece and maybe Spain and
you know gonna list Ireland and so
relative them we probably look okay you
know and we can postpone it for a while
but any little movement I think toward
solving a problem the markets would be
favorably what do you think is most
likely will there be some kind of debt
limit deal that is not just for the
current moment but you know over the
next couple of years in terms of budgets
and well is that the type of signal that
markets need to kind of settle down and
get on with business I think of market
would have loved a four billion dollar
you know four trillion dollar a complete
package and we're not going to see it i
think it's going to be probably
disappointing to the market near term
but they just come up with a trillion
dollar deal or not even that and i just
give they give the president authority
to raise it on their own i mean that's
really kicking the can down the road i
think the market could sell off pretty
strong on that and we're due for a
sell-off anyway so you know near-term
i'm pretty cautious on the market i'm
just saying that there's really no
alternatives eventually when he's got to
come out of banake is forcing people to
take risk which they probably shouldn't
but you know if you can't make any money
on a money market account or a
short-term bonds where else you're going
to go you've been a libertarian for a
long time how did you get interested in
kind of free markets and personal
individual liberty i went to a seminar
and 92 and heard some libertarian speak
and i was always a little confused I
didn't really like what the Republicans
were saying I didn't like the Democrats
and all of a sudden they said you know
this is the way we think the world works
and made all the sense in the world on I
don't understand why everyone isn't a
libertarian
yeah I wish I knew the answer to that
Don Smith I want to thank you very much
for talking to reason TV at freedom fest
day in Las Vegas thank you